Hey, what's going on is bill burn
is time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and
just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on,
oh,
how are you? How are you
everybody? Oh my goodness.
I am down to my last
couple of gigs of the year.
Other than a couple of
benefits or whatever. The last
couple of gigs of the year.
I got Madison Square Garden coming up on
November 7th and then the eighth ninth
and 10th I'm going to be at,
um,
at the Chicago theater and then that's
it. Oh, freckles has done for the year.
Other than a thousand other fucking
local bullshit thinks that I'm doing. Uh,
yeah. So November 7th I'll
be at Madison Square Garden,
but I'm going to be doing
a tuneup show, wink, wink,
nudge nudge at a comedy club somewhere
in Manhattan on November 5th,
a comedy club.
That might be on the west side.
It might be a comedy club.
I'm a west side comedy club.
November 5th, I don't know.
Might be running my hour.
Who knows? I might be there.
I'm going to be there on November
5th. And uh, I love that place.
I love the people that run it.
I'm going to be there.
I'm going to be bouncing around all
over Manhattan, having a great time. Um,
okay.
Getting ready to do that show.
And I'm going to do the MSG with
[inaudible] and Joe Biden. Nick,
I'm going to record that night, this time.
We're going to get it right. And, uh, I,
I am really, really, really, really
looking forward to that. Um, what else?
What else did I have to announce
here? Uh, before the throwback,
there will be a teaser of the,
uh,
the first uninformed patriotic episode.
Patrion goes live.
No vent live November 5th,
next Monday at www.patrion.com/bar.
I got all this extra backstage
shit at the forum. Um,
fly in helicopters. I'm showing
your son some of my, my,
my beauty secrets,
skincare,
stupid shit. Um, and that is all and old.
You know what?
We might have a special guest on this
podcast as special guests that I'm married
to, that I love to death. Who's the
best thing that ever happened to me.
But she's still,
you know,
Piss me off today and I've been doing
such a good job not having arguments with
their own.
I kind of shook it off and then she said
something else to me in the kitchen and
uh, I had do you know, you know, there are
moments where you just have to be like,
hey, you know, you can't talk to me
like that. All right, I'm over here.
I'm paying a swell guy and,
and you know,
so you should be being a sweetheart
and I'm just not, I'm not feeling that.
You know,
feeling like if I'm being like a swell
guy and someone else's not being a
sweetheart, then, then I become a
jerk off. Oh look who just came in.
The person I was talking about,
I'm doing the math here,
the lovely Nia, everybody, the greatest
thing that ever happened to me though.
Yeah. Although if you behave the
way you did this morning every time,
you'd be one of the worst things
that ever happened to me. Oh,
doesn't that sound sincere everybody?
I apologize.
All right. Are you going to sit
down on the couch? So anyways,
um,
I'm sitting there,
you know mine in my own business and uh,
there you go. You sit
down, you sat down. Um,
so Neil, hi, how are you? This is
going to be a little therapy session.
Oh No, it isn't. It isn't, but
you know, you know what I mean?
I get I lovely daughter up. I
guess you said to me, to my face.
Did you let me know I got
these things a little too loud.
Can you turn this down here? Um,
you said to my evidence he face,
she said that you go, you
know, I come upstairs, right?
I worked out. You had a wonderful,
I work out where GRANDPA, um,
I put all this shit. Hey, quit breathing
into the mic. They have breathing.
Yeah,
I put all somebody's going to fucking put
that clip on a loop and jerk off to it.
That's how creepy the Internet is
and have fun. Have Fun with that.
Anyways, um, I put all the shit
from the kid Halloween party,
broke that all down,
put it in the back of my truck.
I noticed that it wasn't huge. Yeah. I
get all of that. I went to the gym. Right.
Being a, being a hell of
a guy. Go upstairs. Right.
All adorable QT face doesn't
want to get up. Yeah. Yup.
She likes to sleep like somebody.
I know. I think that's so adorable.
We got this thing now.
We come in sometimes now when she doesn't,
when you take the blanket off her and
she has this little mischievous grin,
she pulls the blanket back over.
She wasn't ready.
She just was staying lying down and she
wanted me to get the blanket on her.
I was like, come on, it's time to get up.
And she was just smiling at me like, no,
not feeling it.
It was cute.
I just want to stay here for another
couple of 20 minutes. So anyways,
so you leave blanket full.
It's a little chilly.
I was probably your vibe today. Oh. Um,
so right. I get a ride at bed. You leave.
And evidently at some point you said to
me, hey bill, put her in this outfit.
Hey Bill, put her in this
outfit. As you said to me,
here's her outfit for the day.
How many times did you say it?
Once you told me in the kitchen, you
said you said it twice. I sent it to,
you know, I said to you twice and you said
it to my wife. I said it to your face.
To my face. That's the way you
said it. You would like to cop.
You would like to cop reservoir dogs,
buddy.
I am going to shoot you and you don't
put that outfit on our daughter.
So I didn't hear and I saw that Brown
sweatshirt. I put her on that, you know?
Yeah. Can you make more
noise? I'm sorry. Sorry.
Sorry.
What are you doing?
I was trying to think
the tag off this Blake.
Okay, I'm done. I'm done. I'm here.
I'm present. I'm paying attention.
I don't understand why your
mic is so frigging loud.
It's like literally you just moving your
hand. It's making it do all this stuff.
All right.
Anyways.
MMM
yeah. So anyways, so then you're sitting
there, right? She had a poopy diaper,
handled all of that crap,
literally. Right. And then you
come in, you're like, wait,
yeah.
I'm just like, oh, I'm sorry. She
goes, yeah, well why would you do that?
But well she can go to wherever the
whatever event, she's going to win this,
right? You're like, yeah,
but you know it's not going to be
is breathable is what I put out.
So then you leave. So I was
like, all right. By the way,
she's standing there adorable eating the
homemade pumpkin bread than I made last
night.
I'm a sweet guy. I'm a made
guy. Yeah, I'm a swell guy.
Right. So then you leave. And
so what do I own his points,
if you guys can recognize where
that quote is from. Oh, come on.
That's an easy one. Yeah. Just pull
it a little away from your mom. Yeah,
maybe like right here. HAP split the
difference. Yeah. Little muck closer.
How about this? Hey guys, will you keep
adjusting the level that you're time?
That's fine. Anyways. Oh
boy. So then I change.
I change her into the outfit that you
said and you come walking in like nothing
happened. So I jokingly
say, Hey dad, thanks for Ra.
Putting her in the other are the
other outfit. Then you just like,
why don't we have to say thanks.
I told you to put her,
put her in that outfit twice
face. Then you walk out. Yes indeed.
Interface.
Shout out to uh, uh, what's,
what's it like? Oh my God.
A fat sounds fat cells are transforming
fat Sal's and two Mcdowell's yeah.
From coming into him.
Sorry,
I just accidentally hit
that frigging button.
They're reaching for reaching for my
smoothie. Where the hell were we? Oh,
fat cells. Fat Sal's turned
it into what? A Mcdowell's.
And then they also have like
on the side of the building,
they had a big printout and it
says employee of the month, uh,
Keem and as a picture of,
you know Eddie Murphy from
the movie and has restaurant.
Is that and as Jerry Ferrara's right?
That's right.
Our lovely power. Jerry Ferrara. Why did
you have to throw that in Hollywood? Huh?
You can't just say it's owned by him.
Yo,
you always got to do that anyways because
you want to say something like saying
I have my nice about the person so then I
don't know. Yeah, so then you just like,
yeah, I told you that
twice to your face. Right.
I didn't say it like that to your face.
That's how you just said it in the case
to your face. So I don't yell anymore.
That's my thing I kissed. Keeps
saying that Baja ha ha ha. No,
until you're a fucking jerk. It's
something, I mean it is, it is.
There's a reason human beings are able
to yell because God knew that some of
them that he made were church.
So anyways, then I walk,
I'm the king of Mulder now.
I,
Oh yeah,
I'll put the outfit on and when you get
a bucket danger area and I go downstairs
and I'm making a smoothie.
All right. And the,
and the thing is not
supposed to turn on the,
the food processors not supposed to
turn on unless you have the whole thing
closed and it turned out anyways and
stuff is going all over the place and then
you come over, you low think it's
weakened. It's like all over my shirt.
So I give you the look you deserved.
I thought it was like leaking from the
top and him think he realized that it was
coming. No, not from the top. From
the bottom. So I didn't, I don't know.
I didn't realize that most of
that look was because of your,
your thing upstairs in the face.
Right.
So then we're downstairs and
I was just like, hey, you
know, not for nothing. Yeah.
I didn't appreciate you could've
said thank you and you like,
why do I have to say thank you bill?
I told you two times to your face.
That's what you said. And I was just
like, yeah. And then that's when,
that's when I snapped.
I still was saying effin in Gd not
using the actual words. Right, right,
right. I was just like, you're not. Yeah.
You're not going to talk to me like that.
I'm not gonna be a sweetheart and then
be talked to like a jerk because then I
become a jerk off.
I become a typical Staten island jerk off.
I can't believe we're still quoting
that show. So many. I loved it.
I loved it for people.
Never saw that we watch some reality
show and there was this woman from Staten
Island shoe life. I'm a Staten island
girl. Okay. Like the MTV show. True Life.
I'm a blank. This is
true life. I'm a status.
She went into New York and the city
into the city. She went to a club,
she was dancing with a guy.
She had a long island ice tea.
It's just dancing with this guy
and as he's dancing with her,
he's like sorta grabbing is her
girlfriend too? Yeah. And she's like,
are you like, you like grabbing all my
girlfriend? Like why you dance with me?
And the guy's like,
what were the Dayton?
And then they just cut to her outside
of the club and she do cause that.
Was she a typical Staten Island jerk?
Oh
No. I thought he says, well, we're
not married or something like that.
What do we married? Something like that.
Something to that effect. [inaudible]
anyways, he was going for the
threesome and he had just met her.
Got To respect up. There's no
loyalty in the club. Oh Shit.
I think that's got to be,
I think that's got to be on a tee shirt.
But you got to say, you gotta Say
da in Duck Club. No, can't say the,
if you say the,
then you think maybe it's a white club.
Like what are they talking about? The
White House. I know, but like the Senate,
so over Donald, when people
write de whatever on tee shirts,
it's just like Courtney has the
finger on the pulse of social media.
Smith Barney. Oh, it is? What
are the top three emojis?
Uh,
the top of the emojis or the face,
the one where the eyes are closed and
the mouth is kind of like, ah. I'm like,
oh my God, I can't believe this is
happening phase. These are my top three.
I love that one.
I also love the finger on the Chin one
one and then I also liked
the one eyebrow raised.
Those are my faves. You want to
hear mine and the crying laughing.
Of course you want to hit my what
are you and what the thumbs up
that covers everything. Yes, I, yes,
I heard you like point. Yeah,
that sounds good. I feel you.
One of the biggest fucking assholes
I've ever met. She started like,
you know that thumbs up,
speaking of which?
Yes, I got a text message. It's
a way do you forgive me for yeah.
And I'll tell you then I'll, and I'll
tell you why you do apologize. It was,
it was over the top.
And I'll tell you why because I'm done.
I'm done being the angry guy. I don't
give a shit anymore. I'm not too much in.
My life has gone by. I'm on, I'm
on like fucking the 13th hole here.
What am I doing right? 50 years
old. That's a golf reference,
but I don't know what that 13 towards
the end there's only 18 holes. Oh,
so you only have five more
holes lives? Well. I'm 50 okay.
You live to 80 that's a great
run. Although I am drinking. No,
we're going to live longer than that.
Remember I, I'm calling it right now.
You are going to be like the Don Rickles
of your generation and we're going to
like live in Las Vegas.
You and I were going to live in Las
Vegas for like however long they want to
book you for like, Oh we want to give them
a year, a year residency at this place.
We're going to live in Vegas.
We're going to live in one of those
like obnoxious like Penthouse,
five rooms suites in Vegas. It sounds
horrible. Why is it so horrible?
You're going to go downstairs and be like,
hey,
just be pulled out and the jokes old
people tell I'm going to be like shopping
at Caesar's and having lunch
at the same place every day.
They're going to know it's
going to be great getting me.
It's going to be so much fun. You're
going to shop at Caesar's? Yup. Yup.
Cause they have all the stores.
You've got to like there's
just one store and Caesar's.
It's like all the stores that you know,
every time we go to Vegas,
we're there for about 36 hours. You're
like, I gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
That's true.
But I feel like as you're going to live
on the Strip in Las Vegas and this,
this is how you're going to go out
and your golden years. Wow. I mean,
I'm 10 years younger than you, so I'm
not going anywhere for a while, but God,
God willing. I'll come. What? I'm
just saying that would just be fun.
Like if you're 80 and I'm 70 yeah.
Why?
Why don't we just like live in Vegas? Why
not? Yeah. I'm not going out like that.
New and no one is saying you're going out,
but like the cheese,
there's a very high live in fucking Vegas.
Did he do Vegas?
Yeah, he did Vegas. Then he get the
fuck out of there. He'd get another gig.
You think you're going to be on the
road like that when you're 80 years old?
Yeah. First of all, I ever retire at some
point and just do like a nice local gig.
Yeah. It doesn't have to be in Las
Vegas. I'm a fucking redhead. Me,
I'm not going to be with global warming
by the time I'm 80 can be 140 degrees
out in the winter. You'd are you doing
stand up out in the desert like no,
you're inside all those old
people that live in Vegas.
They stay inside the whole time and
Erica and one heat wave like five of them
die. Yeah. Cause I can't make it over to
their fucking air conditioner. I know.
But those are probably the ones who
aren't doing so well financially.
So they can't afford,
they say that they don't
matter and that like, you know,
chances are they're in places that
are caused by wear a silly grin.
The moment you come into view.
There's a lot of older people
who live in Las Vegas, Bill.
So I'm just saying you're going
to be in a significant air,
going to be an air conditioning and
you'll be fine. I'm not going to be there.
I have a plan. Okay. And it's
your plan. As you probably know,
this plan is, well it doesn't involve
fucking living in a shopping. It's
like God living in Las Vegas and
some of noxious fucking penthouse.
Yeah. Looking at hall.
Look at them all down.
How'd he get away from the
window? Yes. Skin cancer.
Oh your ass.
That point we'll be sleeping in
different suites. Jesus Christ.
What was the tech you were
about to talk about? Oh,
getting back comes up. I favorite
emojis. Oh the thumbs up. All right,
so this is thing going on
on the Internet right now.
Cause all Yankee fans are
pissed at not only him,
but a lot of Yankee fans
are pissed at Boston,
at the Boston Red Sox fans that
are talking shit. Right. All right.
There's different kinds of sports fans.
This is sports fan that goes, hey man,
great series you sons of bitches,
you beat us,
whatever and you'll leave it at that.
Then there's the middle guys who just
won't be friends with anybody who's a fan
of another team.
And then there's the worst of the worst,
which are just the shit talk and assholes
who talk fucking shit all the time.
And then when their team loses,
if you can find them,
cause they go into hiding to give
him the shit back that they deserve,
they then act as though
they don't understand where
this is coming from and have
the audacity to be like, oh,
class act, class, act. Right. So,
um, I don't engage in any of that. Right.
Like there's some hilarious stuff
on the Internet right now with um,
you know, shit talking red sox
fans had shit-talking Yankee fans.
One of them is like the one of few Yankee
fans had the audacity to say the Red
Sox bought the, the uh, world
series. Oh, they're mad, Huh?
Well it's just like, well where did
we learn how to do that? You assholes.
They this,
this spending 20 million a year for
like 20 years and this is the first like
couple last couple of years
they'd go with their farm system,
which is brilliant and they're going to
get another one and they're going to get
another one soon is what I think.
As much as I don't want that
to happen as a red sox fan,
I'm also a fan of baseball.
I love what they're doing.
So it's just like all you guys,
all they're doing is stockpiling their
cash and they're going to go out and
they're going to spend a ton of fucking
money and they're going to come out with
it. Whatever the hell you need
to spend now to 228 million.
Is that what it is that what we spent?
Um, and then also go on real class.
He real class, he talking shit.
Baba Baba buy. If the Yankees won,
we wouldn't have said
shit about red sox fans.
It's like the fuck you
wouldn't the fuck you wouldn't,
I remember when you want them
and what you said I was there.
I don't know what you
guys are talking about.
You guys through bear in the face
of one of our relievers this year.
It's stop acting like you're
not face to face. So anyways,
this was the day after,
I'm not going to say who this person is,
but he's a very emotional
person and I love him.
And I've done his podcast and he's done
my podcast and he's one of the funniest
people I know. I love this guy,
but he's out of his fucking mind.
He sends me a text at 12:34 PM he writes,
you know Pedro Martinez Sucks.
Big Fat Elephant Cox still,
he's still suck and elephant dicks.
So I write back, thanks so-and-so.
Exclamation point. God bless, exclamation
point, right? And he just keeps going.
He goes, he doesn't care. He doesn't
clean them either. He just sucks.
Elephant Cock only person
still rocking a Jheri curl.
So then I write back the number 11 and
he's still in the middle of his rent.
He goes, I'm a bad guy now cause
he's, cause he's still sucks cock.
And then he takes the bait and he
goes 11 what? And I go championships,
five super bowls, four world series,
one NBA title one Stanley Cup,
1417 years.
You'll tell your grandchildren about
it and then he just writes back.
You've changed man.
And then he continues. Whatever, man,
you didn't bring back that animal
Schilling and his fake bloody socks.
And I just never responded. So
I don't under, I don't, I'm,
I'm done near you. Don't understand
it. Like I'm going to have relapses.
Like when you bait me two times in the
face, right? That might send me back,
but I am done with this shit.
You just rolled your eyes.
You know what it is near,
you know, you know, in your heart of
hearts, if I fucking beat this thing,
you got nothing on me.
I work hard and make a great living.
I mean,
absolutely.
Absolutely
fucking lovely.
Are you kidding me?
There's shut your cute little face up.
I love you to death you.
I love you to death, but you
know, you, you know something.
Could you quit yawning
into the microphone?
You're fucking dental office waiting room.
All right. I need been on the
podcast and so long. Oh Lord,
I know when People Miss Jen, I
missed Ya. Well, I'm back baby.
I'm back bitches. All right. I need to,
uh, I need to read some advertising here.
This first one's called
nobody.
What?
That's the sound of your voice,
right as I'm walking out the
door to go do something fun.
I just hear you from upstairs.
Swing by is always the opposite direction.
20 fucking miles.
I was going to ask you to bring home some
bananas on the away back from the gym,
but I thought better of it. Oh, you
did? I still would've done it, you know,
but I was like, no,
he's always saying that.
I always ask him to give to the other
day, cause I'm, I'm, I've, I was like,
fuck this,
this is going to be equal.
I asked you when my buddies were
coming up for the world series, I, oh,
you skipped a few steps there. What did
I skip? You asked me to go get some beer.
Yeah. And you said, okay. Oh Jesus. Yeah.
And then a half hour later you're
still laying there and I'm like, yeah,
you gotta go get that beer. And
you're like, oh, you were serious.
It's like, yeah, we're seriously my
row when you told me. So I was like,
you know you had a half hour to get
out of the road. Not to mention, yeah,
it was one in the afternoon. Fucking
laying around. Like who? Ella Deville.
All right, let me, it was this
Sunday. No it wasn't. Yeah,
it was. It was it a Saturday? It was
Saturday. Can you please put the weekends?
We put that back. Why?
Why can't I look at it?
Put that down because I can look
at stuff that's in here now.
It's covered.
It's a fucking,
that's an Elvin Jones modern drummer
magazine. I see that. It's a very like,
you know, like it's obviously
you don't like there's item,
but I can't like pick
it up and look at it.
I wasn't going to take it out
of the packaging. All right.
Can I just read the advertising?
Yeah. All right. Hi.
Nobody wants to feel like they're
overpaying while shopping online,
but did you know there's an easy
way to always get the lowest price?
It's called high.
I don't know why they picked this name.
Honey is a free shopping tool that
automatically saves you money.
Honey,
can I have some money?
That is me though. Yeah, by the Internet.
For the best promo codes.
Whenever you shop online,
that means you get the best deals without
ever trying on your favorite sites.
What would or trying on that means you
get the best deals without even trying on
your favorite sites like
Amazon, Ebay, Walmart, best buy.
Okay.
Newegg, Newegg, Etsy, Groupon in more.
In fact,
honey has are safe
listeners of this podcast.
An average of $46 and
8 cents high knee does.
It does it all for you. It always applies.
The biggest discount right at checkout,
honey has saved the overt,
has,
has over 10 million members and over
a hundred thousand five star reviews.
There's no reason not to add.
Hi.
Hey to your browser today.
Get honey for free and
join honey.com/burr.
That's two words.
Join honey.com/burr hi.
The easiest way to save
money while shopping online,
Barney, shut up. All right.
Jolly Shave Club,
dude.
Dollar Shave Club has
everything you need to look,
feel and smell your best doctor
and you have to go to the Steaua.
Don't have to say, don't go to
this store, swing by the Pat.
You get me a rack of bud light,
a little fucking little nip there.
That's because they deliver everything
you need right to your door.
They keep you fully stocked on what
you use, so don't, so you don't run up.
Here's how it works.
Dollar Shave Club has everything you
need to get ready no matter what yard
getting ready for they have you covered.
Head to toe for your hair, your skin,
your face, you name it, they
have it and they have this,
this new program where they automatically
keep your stock stocked up on the
products you need. You determine
what you want, when you want it,
and it shows right up to
your door for once a month,
what for once a month to once every
six months, however you want to do it.
Plus what they're handsome discount.
Could you quit breathing into the mic
like a fucking pug you? They are like
plus with their handsome discount.
The more you buy,
the more you save and right now dollar
shave club has a bunch of status sets you
can try for just five bucks like
their oral care kit. After that,
the restock box ships regular size
products@theregularpricegetsyoustatussetforjustfivedollarsrightnowatdollarshaveclub.com
slash burr that's dollar shave
club.com/burr what have we got left?
Two more. Two more. Oh
look who it is simply safe.
Simply safe. Nia winds. You like to sit
around your house and filled simply safe.
Here's why I'm a fan of simply safe home.
Simply safe is prepared for
anything that gets thrown at it.
You just send it honey.
If a storm takes out your power,
simply safe is ready and in
true to cut your phone line,
Jesus simply safe is ready.
Say They destroy your key pad
or Siren Nia, simply safe.
We'll still get you help the help you
need. Make sure maybe it's overkill,
maybe you don't need to be ready
for every worst case scenario.
Love how the dragging you back
through your own shit. Well,
why wouldn't I want to be a,
but that's what makes simply safe
home security system so great.
It's always ready. Simply save. Could
cost an arm and a leg, but it doesn't.
Instead they only charge you.
What's failure?
24 seven professional security monitoring.
Monitoring is just 1499 a month
and there are no contracts,
no hidden fees, no contracts, and then
what they, when they don't show up.
I don't know who you guys are.
No paperwork. I'm not kidding.
They're not going to do it.
I recommend simply safe to everyone
I know you got to check it out.
Go to simply safe.com/bird.
That's s I, m p l, I,
s a f e [inaudible] dot
com simply safe.com uh,
to protect your home and family today.
Simply Safe burg.com sorry,
I forgot the bird part lastly,
but not leastly borough.
Sure. Everybody loves it. Donkey.
But have you ever thought about owning
one at [inaudible] dot com kidding
borough makes clever uncompromising
furniture for modern life at home.
Did you realize this?
Nia?
And as the days get shorter
and the weather gets colder,
you know you're going to be
spending more time at home,
on and on and on the couch and on
and on and got all hip hop there.
Make sure that that time well spent
with a sofa from burl handmade in North
Carolina,
Nia,
it's made in America by immigrants has
a Builtin Chad Ya in case that's so for
blocks, a wall outlet.
You liked that? Nia.
Nia, can you just, could
you be involved here?
This isn't money.
Don't want me to like to breathe.
You don't want me like what I'm trying
now you can break this down into the
microphone.
Respectful and let you read
your advertising and you're
still yelling at me like,
what do you want me to do here?
Yeah, that sounds great. They go,
you gotta be that person. Oh,
okay. Yeah. Great. Yeah. Yeah.
He got the charger built into
the sofa. Yeah, it's amazing.
And what's more burrow is designed
for comfort. Exactly 17 inches off the
ground because that's the average height
from the bottom of a person's foot to
the back of their knee.
Includes a built in USB chargers.
So you never get to have to get up. That's
great. Let's do that. Read again. Yeah.
Okay, let's do that. Read again. All
right. I liked that you said that's great,
but I want more emotion
this time. Okay. All right.
Includes a built in Usb chargers so
you never have to get up. That's great.
That's okay. Now just,
okay. That was, that's good.
But I want late night TV.
People have fallen asleep. Okay.
You got to get them to buy a sofa to 48
in the morning. All right, they're ready.
Got It. I'm ready. Here we go.
Includes a built in USB chargers.
So you never even have to get up.
That's great. Oh, and even more.
Introducing new line of pillows.
I come on,
keep the energy up and throws
four unique collections.
Help you decide in your style.
That was terrible.
F The f ethically manufactured,
you'd say ethnically.
Ethnically manufactured.
Ethically manufactured with fair
trade and good. We've certification.
Oh,
you can get your living room ready for
fall and save $75 $75 $75 on a new sofa
by visiting [inaudible] dot com
slash burr for your $75 order.
Shipping is fast and it's free.
That's borough B,
U. R. R. O. W.
Dot com slash bird gets $75 off
your oral order. Sorry, Aura.
Thanks again to burrow
for supporting the show.
When a flight a fuck do they
throw that in the weight had?
How's that spelled
again? B. U. R. R. O. W.
If this isn't the greatest couch with a
plugin phone charger, you ever sat on it?
All right.
What are we up to here?
31 minutes, Nia. Just like that. Yeah. I
swear to God, I love you to death and I'm,
I'm done getting into fights with you.
Okay? I'll ask both agree to that.
Have you noticed that?
Had been trying to say it.
Yes.
I have noticed that you have tried.
The old me would have taken that bait.
You know what this is.
That's not even a you thing.
I was assertive to be funny
in that moment. I've noticed.
I've noticed that you've tried.
I've been married too fucking long.
Ever expect a compliment.
I know what the deal
is. Well, you should be.
You should have been doing this the
whole time. That's what it's going to be.
And this is what I want this
and better late than never.
This is what I, and this is
what I want you to do. You,
I want you to continue to
not work on yourself. Yes,
yes and I, and I'm, I'm going to become,
I'm going to become such a good person.
People are going to start
whispering to me. Why are you,
she's horrible. Welcome to my world. Now
I am working on myself.
You know that I'm working on myself.
You start putting words in my mouth.
What are you Trump? What do you mean?
I'm great. You know,
I'm working on myself.
No one's worked harder on themselves
than I have. I am the greatest work
around myself ever. Um, anyways. Hey,
I want to thank everybody that's coming
out to Madison Square Garden. Um,
I'm recording that night and please come
down and I have a couple of glasses of
booze. Get all fucking leg.
That's right. Loosen up.
I'm going to have a great time.
I'm fucking going up neon.
Been going harder than ever on
stage just because of all of this.
They keep asking.
I wish I could
be there for Madison Square Garden.
I know it's going to be amazing because
the form was literally the best show
I've ever seen. You do. And I've known
you for years isn't I'd like to count.
Yep. Um, now it's like the
best show I've ever seen.
You do and I've seen you
do like amazing shows.
But that forum one was like,
even when I talk to people about it now,
they'll just say it just from the
moment we walked in the door like that,
it's just the whole energy was electric
and I think the crowd was really excited.
You had a great crowd that night.
Like it was just, yeah, the crowd was,
it was really, really, yeah.
It was just great energy.
And like Joe and dean were bulges
on their a game. Like it was just
it, well Joe and dean walked out there
like they were doing a spot at the store,
which is like how you have
to be, right? Yeah, no,
they just went out there and they were
just like, Hey, what's up? And just, yeah,
when I was like, all right, well let
or intimidated by the venue, I guess.
If they're not nervous, why should
I be? No, I'm very, uh, yeah, no,
it's a humbling experience in go out day,
just like,
I don't know if I ever get to
do this again. So I'm playing.
Yes. That's a, that's like your new
thing now is that you play the drums and,
and do then jam and then either they like,
I feel like you shake all the
nerves out of you by doing it.
Yeah. You just go, why don't you
just make a ton of noise? Yeah.
I did that at the garden and Boston.
I'm going to do what an MSG again
and a that the form too. Yup.
Oh, I played for like almost three
hours. My shoulder was killing me.
That's so great that they
let you do that though. Yeah.
Well at first I thought that
they would think that, yeah. Why?
What does this asshole doing that,
but then it's like this bands in
there all the time. 200 and up. Yeah.
And I think that they get a
kick out of the fact that, uh,
that we're acting like we won a
radio contest rather than coming in.
They're like, oh, another arena.
Right? Yeah. We come and they're like,
[inaudible] can't believe I'm here.
I mean, that's all we do. I saw Queens
of the stone age here that just,
I just freak out the whole time.
I'm there.
Wait, are we not going to talk
about the party yesterday?
Oh, how much you crushed that
frigging party? We had a,
the second annual kid, Halloween
baby Halloween, maybe Halloween,
maybe Halloween party.
You know how nightclubs are 21 and over.
This is, this was two years
and under and under that one.
It was adorable. First of all, but
now it was, it was really good.
The one little kid dressed
like a hedgehog. Oh my God.
The two little kids dress like hedgehogs.
There was two hedgehogs at the party.
I know. I thought that it was
gonna be friction. Um, snoopy, the,
the one family, one family came
dressed as Charlie Brown and Lucy.
That was the parents. And then snoopy was
the baby. Oh my God. It's so cute. There.
We had the tires,
the tires.
I love the tires that parents
showed up and just their,
their bathrobes and pajamas and they
kid. Oh, someone who's pajamas. Uh,
it was a very clever idea. It was you
went out and got us all skeleton costume.
Oh my God, wait, can we talk
about your skeleton cuts?
My skeleton slash gimp outfit that
you got me. It was a giant one.
Z with feet and hands. I didn't realize
that there was like gloves and feeding.
It wasn't clubs. It was all sewed
into it. There was no option,
there was no option.
Then we found out later on that night
that there was actually like the ski mass
thing that you were supposed to put
over your head. Like are you serious?
It was. It was definitely freaky. Yes.
And then you had the
most craziest joke ever.
Yeah. Last night I go,
Jesus Christ, they go,
there was a fucking ski mask thing
with that and then you laugh,
you said put that on and fuck me.
And I was even a even that
made me uncomfortable.
And I know you were fucking
joking obviously, but I
was like Jesus Christ Nia.
Cause it literally looked like it again.
Put it over your head. And it was, I guess
skeleton. The only thing that was
missing was the zipper mouth. So offline.
So scary. Yeah. That was a
one and done or put that on.
Fuck me.
Unbelievable.
Oh my God.
Horrible. But no, that was
um, that was a fun time.
Thank you so much for your help with
that. All right, great. Okay. Okay.
I am, I'm going to take you
to a Mike class at some point.
You literally have it laying
horizontal across your chest. I know.
Could I be like any laser
zero right now with my energy.
I'm comfortable now. I'm finally in a
comfortable spot. I got the blanket.
I felt good.
Yeah,
you were supposed to be working right now.
He's supposed to be this training people
and you're sitting there looking more
like a,
they took vacations together.
MMM.
All right. No, but the uh,
the caterers were amazing.
All the food was amazing and thank
you Twitter for your ear playlist
suggestions. I think people on Twitter,
but I want to thank you guys again.
You crushed it.
So a lot of good ideas.
You had all this great music and then all
of a sudden it would just go into like
thriller Michael Jackson and
everybody get all psyched at that.
And then it'd be something
that would be like baby Shaq,
Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee baby should,
I was trying to do that.
Does that song go once that's
in your head, you're done.
It's done. It's done. And I
had three different versions
of, are you seeing areas?
Yeah, I don't remember. Baby Shark.
Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee baby
check Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee
baby check mommy. Shucked it
duty. It doesn't go to do, to do,
to do to, no, it doesn't. How does it go?
It doesn't do that. You didn't even hit,
you didn't even know what the
song was until I played it.
So how do you know how it goes?
How's it go then? I don't remember,
but it doesn't go like that. Yeah. Well
there's, there's a few different versions.
There's a slower one that goes baby
shock Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo do
doo baby sharp dude, dude, dude,
that's the one baby shower.
Maybe Shark Dude. Dude, dude,
bitch, the fuck is up. There
is a many different versions.
Face Dude, dude, dude, dude,
dude, dude, dude, dude, dude.
The judge your face
fast one though.
That was the first one I heard.
Maybe that was the first one I heard.
Oh wait, maybe it works with that voice.
And then I heard BB and then there's an
RMB version one that I play at the party
as well I think is firing on all cylinder.
Oh they're a spicy Margarita.
Has two of those bad boys.
All kinds of delicious food. We had like
the toys and the games out for the kids.
Yeah, it was a good time. It was a
good time. Yeah. And now it's over. No,
it's so far right now I have to go
return all those tables and chairs.
How cute with the little kid chairs.
Oh,
and they actually sat in them and they
were coloring and putting stickers on
construction paper.
It was so cute.
I like the little kids at that age.
Like they just like there'll be two
little kids just looking at each other and
another kid just runs up super fast.
And then just stops and then he'd just
stare at each other and then they all
just run to go to something.
You know, our, um,
our neighbor texted me and she
was asking how the party was,
she has older kids and she was like,
you probably had a much more controlled
situation cause her kids are older and
she's like, when they get older, once
it's like foreign ops, she's like,
every party is completely
insane because it's,
their energy is all over the place anyway.
And then they have candy and she was like,
please enjoy like the kind of controlled
atmosphere that you have with this age
group. But I was like, no, I know.
That's why I wanted to keep it to one
under cause they're just insane. Right?
Like don't you think?
Uh, no, I wasn't aware of any
of this storm front. Yeah.
Well apparently, well, whatever
I'm going to comment on.
Oh Wow. What are you going to do?
Yeah, I mean whatever happens,
I know that me and my siblings did
tenfold to my mother, so I have a common,
um, all right, that's the
podcast. Um, now I go,
now we're going to be listening to a clip
of a uninformed. I'm the first one in,
I don't know how many years. 10 years.
That's got to be on the Patrion page.
That is going to be debuting November 5th,
November 5th.
Excuse me,
I just burped November 5th.
You're going to talk to me
about microphone etiquette.
You know what? You're right. See
that guys, that's how it works.
You want to get along with your wife.
Just learn that phrase. You know what?
You're right. All right. That's it.
Have a wonderful weekend. Your consent.
Dionne.
I never one of those ones do it.
If I could go back in time.
I've worked in so many kitchens.
I've never seen so many jail bird.
I've never seen him get over and
fucking wash some. I've never,
we're going to get you. I've never seen
so many fat men do so much cooking.
It's like, Dude, oh, this doesn't make any
fucking say no. I've told you this story.
I got a classic one, our manager, right?
The manager where I
worked. Uh, I was a busboy,
so I used to have to mop up around the
oyster bar and they had like the black
and white towels like the old
improv's used to have. Right.
So I'm mopping that up and I'll
always be a fucking mess. Yeah.
And then I would have to mop up and
clean the men's room and the women's room
and a women's room always look like,
you know,
like the Yankees just
won the world series.
It was just like toilet paper and ticker
tape all over the whatever. It was just,
it was a fucking mess in that guys who
was just a pissed all over the place.
So I go in there to clean the
bathroom and my manager is in there.
He's got the water on full blast and
he's brushing his teeth while puking.
Swear to God he's prejudice,
maybe go like,
oh wow.
And he had the water and keep going and
then he just kept brushing his teeth and
I was sitting there,
I didn't know what to do.
Aw.
They just
kept brushing his fucking teeth and then
he just saw it and then he played it
off going like, ah, you know,
it goes brushing the teeth sometimes
it makes me gag and I'm thinking about
though, fucking jam the toothbrush
down your throat, your fucking whore.
And it wasn't till I was only 19 right.
So what does it until years later that I
was like, oh, he was fucking hung over.
He just was fucking puke it up alcohol
and he was probably standing there puking.
Then I came in and then he was just trying
to act like he was brushing his teeth.
Like I wasn't going to notice
that he was fucking puking,
but I was standing there and go over
the brush. Gee, that guy was stuck.
I was so funny. I remember he'd
go for it, believe it or not,
he ends up getting fired.
Right? He gives to, yeah,
he gets fired and then he
gets a job managing another
restaurant as they all do.
Yeah. You walked out onto the floor and
an eight ball fell out of your pocket,
you're fired. And then like
they won't even go across town.
They'd be across the fucking,
like the, the, the Strip mall.
So this guy ends up getting another job,
making way more money and I swear to God,
he showed up like a week
later with his new job,
he had bought a brand new car
and he came over to peacock,
like we gave a fuck and he pulled up
with some white Subaru sports cars.
I can't even know what the fuck he had.
And he just kicked can,
he just was sitting there at
the fucking bar with this cat,
ate the canary smile on his face. I said,
hey man, how you doing? I said, hey,
is that your karate? He's
like, yeah, I want to drive it.
And he slid the keys across the barge.
Jesus Christ. Yeah. I swear to God.
It was like I was in road house. The Dude
restaurant workers are like dirty cops.
They just get shuffled off. Oh, you
dirty fucking precinct. Oh yeah. No,
you're there once you're in your
end, dude. It doesn't matter.
No Monday,
Eh,
yes,
it's back.
So oops.
Can't, you can't, you
can't. You can't. You cards.
What's going on? It's Bill Burger.
It's the Monday morning podcast.
That was the worst fucking mix ever done.
I don't give a fuck. I'm in my pajamas.
What do you want for me?
The Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November 1st. Oh my God.
It's almost thanks Kevin.
This motherfucker is back on iTunes,
so everybody relax you
a fucking smart phones.
Okay, relax. You can
download it. It is back.
I don't know why it's back.
I don't know why it went away.
It went away like somebody
drunk mother a couple of months,
you know, couple of months back. She
started drinking. This Shiv is Rico.
Yeah.
Got a little tipsy.
She went out to the bar and she never
came back and then all of a sudden she
just comes walking back into our
lives. No apology. No nothing.
Ma. Where the fuck you Ben.
Okay. Jerry. Just it alone.
All right. She's sober.
Um, yeah, I dunno what,
I don't know what happened with fucking
iTunes. I don't know what I said.
I don't know what I did.
There was no explanation.
Actually there wasn't an explanation, but
it's too fucking boring to get into. Um,
I use the wrong punctuation.
Some sort of quotes when I put the
money more. No, I used an Asterick,
you know, little Barry bonds, little
Sammy Sosa, little Mark McGuire,
little Roger Maris action when I went
to go post it and then they just,
they just took me off, you know, and
like some mean little seventh grade girl,
they just refuse to talk to me.
We were BFFs and it was fucking
over and there was no reason,
complete overreaction.
So for the last fucking 35
days is so we were like, dude,
what the fuck are, you know, I thought
we were friends. So anyways, we're back.
We're back on iTunes and if you guys have,
you know,
your smartphones or whatever the
hell it is, you can download it.
You can download it to your iPod, you
can go right back to fucking off at work.
Isn't that great? Isn't that phenomenal?
Doesn't that make you feel good?
Uh, as you could see, uh, I kind of
sound excited. This is like one of these,
these episodes where I'm going to be
a little manic because not only am I
excited that the eye, uh, the
podcast is back on iTunes.
I'm also a freaking out cause I have
a ton of shit that I have to do today.
So to be honest with you guys,
after this wonderful Intro,
I'm just here to tell you I really don't
have time for you fuckers this week.
What are you think about that?
Um,
all right, what are we going to
talk about this week? Let's, let's,
let's open the page.
Is Open the page Nia closing the
door cause I'm being too loud.
It what's it matter Nia?
He afraid of the funny,
she's in a mood, but
aren't they always? Oh,
I got a smile and it really
annoyed me this weekend. Uh, I was,
I was in Saint Louis, Mi
me in Saint Louis, Louis,
me,
me at the fair though.
Tell me the lights are shining
and he plays spot there.
We will dance though. Who Cheat?
Coochie. You will be something else.
That is a sexual innuendo bond.
It's the 19 fucking forties.
So we can't talk about banging.
I'm sorry,
Mitch Miller Baby.
What was my first album?
Sing along with Mitch and the gang and
I just found out that motherfucker just
died. That son of a bitch was
like 90 something years old.
Still Putting Grecian formula and
his beard. God bless them. Um,
not Jesus.
Why did I sing that stupid fucking song?
I forgot what the hell was going
to talk about. Let's go back.
Let's try to go back into the memory bank.
I was in Saint Louis this week and uh,
I did a benefit for the children,
John Carney carnies kids.
I did that a Friday night,
Saturday night.
I did the funny bone two
shows that the funny bone.
I want to thank everybody who showed
up at a wonderful time out there.
And um, if you guys want to go back in
time and reach back into a little bit of
Americana that you feel was lost during
the last 20 years of horrific moves,
you know, I got an idea.
Let's come up with Nafta.
Let's stand all the manufacturing
out of this fucking country.
And then someday when we want a fact
we got to compete with sweatshop labor.
Does that sound like good idea?
I think that's a good fucking idea.
I have an idea. Let's have a war. Fuck.
Let's have two wars at
the same fucking tab.
How are we going to pay for it? Borrow
money from China. That sounds good to Mei.
Why am I blaming it on southerners?
I Dunno why.
I Dunno.
Why?
Because the last two guys were from
Arkansas and then the other guy was from
Texas.
You know La.
You realize before Obama,
the last two presidents should have
been on the food network or one of those
barbecue offs.
You know I'm trying to compete.
Who has the best fucking sauce?
Mine's vinegar based and his,
his is more molasses. Okay.
That's that sweet stuff.
You put that sweet stuff phone cause
you don't know how to cook a good piece
mate. You're not a good, you
know how to cook. Good Pace. Me.
You don't need go desk fleets up
equally. Little bit of vinegar. Ireland.
I come from the foot hills North
Carolina we use, we use vinegar. Sorry.
He started using that, then that sweet
stuff he talks about Kansas City. Um,
anyway,
so if you want to,
if you want to reach back into America
a little bit and just a, if you want to,
if you have children and you want them
to see what this country used to be like
back in the day when you
could eat cheeseburgers and
French fries and a fucking
drink it God damn chocolate
malt and somehow not end
up being a fat fuck because
there wasn't all these God damn
preservatives in it. Right?
Isn't that what it makes you fat?
How can I make people used to eat like
no one knew shit about nutrition in the
1950s yet everybody kind of
seemed like they weren't in shape.
You know, granted they were
fucking openly racist and uh,
grabbing their secretaries
ass every five seconds,
but they were in much better shape.
If you want to go back into time,
go to Saint Louis because St Louis is
one of the few places I have been to and
the last eight years that you can still
smoke in comedy clubs and you could
smoke in bars and people just light
up. And I, and I was amazed by it,
you know,
even though I kind of remembered that
you hadn't been there in five years, but,
uh, there's just certain states they just,
they just, um, they don't give a shit.
Like when they see the surgeon
general come on TV, they just like,
I don't recognize that uniform. He
ain't no fucking Americans. So, uh,
they completely ignored. So if you want
to go back in time with your child,
you know,
if you're tired of reminiscing with your
adolescent son or daughter about how I
used to be able to go in a bar
and have a drink and a smoke,
why not live it?
Why not go to Saint Louis?
I think that they should add that to
their tourist attractions right up there
with the, uh, with the arch,
the gateway to the west,
so to speak. I actually hung around for
an extra day yesterday and I went to the,
uh, the Saint Louis Rams
game first. The, uh, the,
uh, the Carolina Panthers and is
boring as part of the game was,
it was kind of exciting to watch a team
that you could tell was going to be
fucking good. And about
a year or two, the ramps,
remember you heard it
first, November 1st, 2010,
right here at Sam Bradford I think
is the real fucking deal. Guys.
Cool as a cucumber.
He's driving the damn team down the field,
even though his top three receivers
are all out for the season.
He was throwing it to
white guys all day long.
That's how many injuries
they have on that team.
They're all the way down to
the white receivers people.
And I know what you're going to
say. What about Wes? Welcome.
All right, Wes Welker, that white dude
who played for Denver, there's not a lot,
you know, but slowly but surely, I don't
know if you've noticed the white guy is,
is, is making a little bit of
inroads back into, into some, uh,
what do they call those
positions? Performance or a
speed positions. You know,
there's a couple of white running backs.
Did you ever think you're going to see
that again? I mean, I couldn't believe it.
I'm in Saint Louis.
People are smoking within structures and
there's a white quarterback thrown to a
white wide receiver. It
was unbelievable. It was,
I was waiting for Larry Zonker to come
walking out on the field with that little
fucking, you know, the two
bars across his face. And then
that one, the, the, the, the,
the horseshoe he had on top.
That's why I don't fucking
respect the God damn. 72 dolphins.
They had two white running
backs. Okay. And you go, oh,
we went undefeated. Did Ya?
Who'd you play in the third week? Some
group of people from the fucking why MCA?
You fucking pricks. What'd
you have? 14 you've 40.
I need to do is win 14 fucking games.
14 game season.
You cheap bastards.
Oh God.
That fucking loss to
the giant still hurts.
But you know what feels good watching
the Goddamn jets lose nine to nothing.
I love it.
And here are the Patriots are
right in a rebuilding fucking year.
We've got a bunch of God damn kids
play in defense. We Trade Randy Moss,
all these asshole Jeff fans a fucking go.
Oh with the Patriots.
Fucking quit with a nervous. They could
be the judge. The today picked up Dave.
That's what a great coach bill Belicheck
is. All right, you fucking assholes.
How do you like that?
Six and one with a bunch of
children playing defense.
Six and one best record in the NFL.
I don't know how the fuck we did it.
I got it.
I got to admit I'm not gonna.
I'm not going to believe that we're
actually going to do something.
And unless we, we beat
the Steelers and, uh,
we play the Steelers in the jets and a,
even if we go one on one,
if we're competitive, then I'm, I'm
going to get excited. But, uh, you know,
I dunno with our defense at this point
is halfway to be in good, I feel,
but I'm, I'm telling you don't
sleep on the fucking rams.
I should have bet those sons of bitches
I show I had no idea what was going on
down there in Saint Louis.
And they got that maniac. Uh,
the fuck is his name, number
55. That kid from Ohio State,
God damn it, what the hell
was his name? Something itis.
Dad's like a professional wrestler.
He went in and he got a sack and he
did the fucking Hulk Hogan, you know,
putting his cup in his ear and then
he did the flex and then I was great.
It was fucking great.
I Dunno what the jets lost.
I'm so fucking excited. Cause all those
assholes and you know, it's funny,
I didn't get one goddamn fucking email
from any of those goddamn jet fans who've
been giving me shit all these
weeks. You know, fucking idiots.
They're not idiots. You know what they
are? They're hopeful. Sons of bitches,
they have a one in 40 years.
They get excited about little things
like drafting fucking Mark Sanchez,
Sanchez.
You know what's going to be the end
of the jet season if one of your
unbelievably awesome offensive lineman
goes down with an injury that fucking
goddamn mediocre overrated
jackass. Overrated. This week,
mark fucking Sanchez,
that gay managing jackass.
Good Lord fucking sit behind
the Goddamn Berlin Wall.
You could have fucking rex Grossman in
there and he could throw for 180 yards.
No picks. You're not impressing
me. Speaking to that man,
I had the fucking reds.
I got my ass handed to me yesterday.
Thank God I picked the dolphins,
the dolphins getting one
and Cincinnati and a,
I love the dolphins.
I loved them.
They got that fucking defense and the
Bengals have been sputtering all fucking
year. So I said, fuck it. I'll
take death. So I won that one.
Then I had the Redskins, Donovan McNabb
going into play the lines, but typical me,
I don't read up on sports.
I didn't know that their quarterback
was coming back for the lines.
I don't even know what his fucking
name is. Stafford, something like that.
I had no fucking idea. And then when,
when the whole game's on the line,
including my fucking money,
you take Donovan McNabb out
and you put in Rex Grossman,
the guide,
the cult secretly fucking paid
off the bears to be quarterback.
So Peyton manning could finally get his
fucking ring after they went into the
Goddamn rule book and change the rules
so Peyton could fucking actually beat the
patriots in the fucking playoffs,
playoffs and whatever.
And I'm just talking shit.
I actually took the colts tonight.
As much as I hate it,
I'm going to have to fucking root for
the colts because I could go up to games
on Paul Versey who almost went all in
for last week. Missed. I know sports.
Paul Versey, are you listening? He
went one in three yesterday and I uh,
I've got one or two, but I have, I
have the colts tonight. Loving them,
loving them to avenge their
loss to the Houston Texans.
I don't even know what the fucking
spread is cause I don't give a shit.
I really don't give a shit. I just
like pissing people off. Let's get,
let's get home with the podcast.
Um, it is November 1st everybody.
And um, did you guys all have a nice
Halloween? Did you have a nice Halloween?
Do, did Brett Farve die yesterday? Did
you guys see that shit? Jesus Christ,
he looked like somebody kicked
him in the balls from behind.
The way he was laying there with
his fucking knees up to his dealer.
He was going to get an enema. It's
like, what are you doing to do dude?
You own every fucking record out there.
Good and bad.
What are you going for? The mediocre
ones now I don't understand this guy.
It's just, just, just walk away.
I don't like how he's patting himself on
the back too. You know, I got hit in a,
that's a hit that, you know, I don't think
a lot of people would've got up from,
but you know, I had on some
wrangler underwear and I just said,
fuck it. He is a tough son
of a bitch. But you know,
I don't know what he's trying this, his
wife hate him at this point. Um, yeah,
keep playing. I don't give a shit show
and you dick to everybody. Fuck you.
Um, oh, here's something that I actually,
I never even addressed.
All right. Brett said that,
that annoyed me and Colby Bryan a couple
months ago when Lebron was doing his
big decision thing,
when he finally decided to go to Miami,
Coby made this statement,
I forget if I brought this up.
They ask Coby if he would have done the
same thing and he goes, no, I wouldn't.
I would've stayed. And a, I thought
that was kind of Kentucky. It's like,
well that's easy for you to say when
you fucking play for the Lakers and they
bring all the free agents to you.
You know,
there's been no reason
for you to fucking leave
your whole fucking career.
They've been bringing you guys,
you were playing in Cleveland.
You would have left Colby.
You almost left because you didn't like
Shaq either. He goes through, I go,
I'm sick of when it championships.
Um,
it's all fucking career. They
brought you Shaq, Dennis Rodman,
Phil Jackson, Karl Malone,
Gary Payton, Robert Henri,
[inaudible], Saul, fucking that dude
who choked the people that I had off.
I don't watch fucking basketball.
Who's that guy there?
A Jesus Christ. So he, he's still
a bit of bottom. I say his name.
Every God damn night teams. Jermaine
O'Neal slid across the floor,
punch that guy in the face. Ah,
whatever the fuck his name is.
Latrelle fucking third cousin.
They've brought you a list.
Fucking free agencies.
Your entire Goddamn Korea.
I thought that was a real
country move for someone who,
who is allegedly Lebron's friend.
But how funny is it watching, uh,
Lebron's people sitting there trying to
do damage control with these stupid ass
fucking commercials?
Trying to get people to a,
I don't know what changed their
opinion about him. I mean,
I could really give a shit. It's just
like, just fucking go play basketball.
I don't give a fuck. What
would I do that? Well,
what would I, what would I do? I would,
I would not even be able to make it on
my eighth grade basketball team if I
remember correctly. So I, I don't
know what I would do. Lebron.
I haven't had to make decisions
like anywhere near that level.
I don't care. I don't
care about you. And yet,
talcum powder and your little
fucking ritual. I could give a shit.
Just fucking go out and entertain me.
I don't need you to try to Redo your
fucking image, you know? I don't know.
So what,
you can make $100 billion.
Don't you have enough? Isn't it
enough? You get free sneakers?
I don't even know what
I'm talking about people.
I'm just fucking thinking about all the
shit I have to do for the rest of the
day. That's what I'm doing
in this podcast right now.
I'm cleaning the dirt out
of my keyboard and, uh,
speaking in what, you
know, what I'm dying to do,
I'm dying to fucking replace
some of the tile in my bathroom.
You know, this is the latest
thing I'm obsessed with.
I'm obsessed with learning how to fix
shit around the house because I'm going to
buy a house and I'll be fucked if I'm
going to pay some fucking mouth breathe in
jackass with Dickies hanging off
his goddamn ass to come in there and
overcharged me for parts cause he wants
to have a fucking kegger that weekend,
you know? So if you want to learn
how to do shit right, I eat this.
You do it. You do it in the
apartment that you're living in.
See, like my dog clawed
up some of the, uh,
some of the trim around
the door and a man,
it's a fucking joke. I'm looking
at it going, this is this,
this can't be this fucking difficult.
I'd go down to home depot,
they got precut shit down there,
so all I gotta do is get the shit
that's the same fucking size.
I trim it off the bottom,
make sure it fits.
Slap it on there. Right.
Who cares if I fuck up?
It's not my place. It's all a little bit
of pain over. Nobody's going to notice.
My landlord doesn't listen
to this podcast, does he?
No. Seriously. I want to.
I want to learn how to fucking do that.
Some of that shit already
know how to take a toilet out.
Can take the whole fucking thing apart.
I know how to take a fucking sink out now.
I don't know how to do that shit.
I just watched a couple youtube videos,
but it gave me confidence.
I'm confident with the sink that you,
you fucking set down into the counter.
That one that you got
to go underneath with.
I don't know how that's when
you're dealing with gravity.
I like the one that sits down in it.
You can just unhook everything and then
figure out how to hook it back up later.
You know you go to turn on the hot
water and all of a sudden the garbage
disposal goes on in the fucking kitchen.
I want to learn how to do that shit,
but, uh, I don't know what the
fuck I'm talking about. All
right, let's, let's, let's,
let's get to some youtube videos
of the week people, shall we, um,
first one and these are all going to
be, uh, on the, uh, the man podcast.com,
the official website of the Monday morning
podcast that is back on iTunes as you
heard earlier with my horrible
singing. Um, all right. Here,
they all are in, these aren't,
these aren't even youtube videos.
These are videos that I got everywhere,
but youtube because a,
everybody's on Youtube,
so I'm trying to go a little bit outside
the box with some of the shit that
people send me. Um, this is one.
Um, ah, shit, I didn't know
what the fuck to call it.
Just go to the [inaudible] podcast.com
and check this one out. Um,
a buddy of mine stand up, comedian,
uh, Rob Cantrell, fucking hilarious.
Really original guy. Um,
comedian and I think, um,
I think it was the first season
of last comic standing he was on,
that's the first time I saw him.
And I was like,
I like this dude because he doesn't seem
like he's trying to win the competition
as much as he's trying to give
these people some quality stand up.
And then you had the other guy fucking
going around with the Goddamn Ginsu Sorge
fucking spinning it around. So of
course America votes for him. Right?
That's how they do it. Gimme some
shiny shit. That's what I'm voting for.
Um, he did a thing about why pot
should be legalized in this country.
He made a great fucking
video that's supposed to, uh,
it's supposed to be like the
beginning of that movie patent. Um,
check that one out. Uh, there's
another one, a dude with Nub,
k Kaos another guy.
It's a guy with a,
yeah,
he has only one arm and then he has
part of another arm and he fucking,
he's in a,
I don't know what to do and Muay Thai
and he movie knocks the other guy's
fucking ass down out of the camp canvas.
Um,
next one is a touch my body karaoke fail,
uh, with some English subtitles, even
though the guy's singing in English.
And the last one actually comes from
the dude who runs the EMM podcast,
who if you want to really,
if you want some advice on gambling,
this is the guy he's on
a fucking hot streak,
a crazy racist in coffee shop.
Starts yelling at Mexican dude.
So there you go.
There's your videos that you can watch
while you're at work or working out or
whatever. Um, I got a lot of
emails last week from me imitating
those dudes on the corner,
so called white man. That shit.
Remember that last week? Um,
somebody said a then pression
of the street preacher
with the bad pa was spot on
and fucking hilarious.
There's a guy shouting in Spanish into
a blown out PA on the weekends in my
neighborhood, there's two churches. Uh,
there's two churches on every block.
And even the immigrants, immigrants,
resonance, even the immigrant residents,
these, this all misspelled here.
Immigrant residents grimace and give
him dirty looks. How do you say,
quit shouting and fix
your levels in Spanish?
That is a reoccurring thing that I
have found straight across the board.
When people go out, I don't give a
fuck black, white, Latino, Asian.
I don't give a shit. They never
have the levels correct in their PA.
I think there's so passionate about their
politics that they never really, uh,
I don't know.
And it's such a grass roots
actually,
when you think about it,
do you really think Obama knows
how to use a mixer? How old is he?
Yeah, he probably doesn't.
He's like fucking,
I don't even know how old the guys I
have not paid attention to politics in.
I don't even know when. I have no
fucking idea when I just, I want,
whenever I stopped talking
about conspiracy theory
theory cause I just got so
depressed about all of
the shit, um, you know,
started reading up on banking.
Like here's a,
here's something interesting here.
I,
this is one way I kind of see both sides
of this. This guy sent me this letter.
He said about bill,
listen to this shit.
So my wife and I are looking at
buying a house. Uh, like you,
I am not the biggest fan of banks.
So instead of putting all my
money in a savings account,
I had been saving some cash on the
side and keeping it in my dresser.
And there's a smart place to put it.
Why don't you stick it in the mattress?
There's another, a
place you know, through,
if you ever had that money stolen by
somebody breaking into your house,
that burglars should have been dressed
up in the black and white stripe shirt
with the, uh, uh, lone ranger.
I'm a fucking a bank
robber. A mask. Maybe.
Maybe you just saying you
put it in your dresser,
your actually put it somewhere
else. You know, you gotta Cook.
You gotta be a little more creative
than that. Uh, anyways, he says, well,
when my wife talked to the bank about
getting alone, they asked us our incomes,
how much money we saved and how we
would be paying our down payment.
My wife sold in about our
savings and everything was fine.
She then told them that I had
cash saved up on the side.
They immediately stopped her and said
that the cash could not be used unless
there was an explanation for how I got
it and a paper trail to back it up.
The banks look at your financial history
bank statements and your spending
habits to determine if you really could
save however much cash you actually
have. A, since some of my money is cash,
I've won from poker games and old stuff.
I sold on craigslist,
craigslist.
I have no paper trail for it.
The only way that I can now use it for
our house is to get my parents to lie and
write a note explaining to the bank that
they gave me the money as a gift and
I'm not sure if that will work because
I don't know if they will check my
parents bank risk records to confirm
that the whole policy is bullshit.
I understand that the bank's fucked up
and had to foreclose on a lot of people
and they want to make sure that I'm
not paying for a house with drug money,
but come on.
This essentially means that if I'm walking
down the street and find $20,000 in
cash in an alley, take it and
try to use it as a down payment.
The banks won't let me because
there's no record of how I got it.
This whole ordeal really pisses me off
and I'm pretty sure it goes back to what
you're trying to say about
how the government is trying
to phase out cash money.
Uh, no, that doesn't, that's,
that's one of those double standard
things that they do where you have to
produce all this paper trail stuff to
show that you're not a piece of shit.
But they, on the other hand, the
Federal Reserve I'm talking about, um,
they've never been audited and we gave
them $1 trillion bail out money and it
just disappeared in the thin air.
They can't say who got it or where it
went and they're not being audited.
But you, on the other hand, you know,
you sell an old skateboard and
your original fucking playstation,
you win some money down the street and
a poker, you know, a poker tournament,
none of that Shit. You know, you're
supposed to pay taxes on all of that shit.
And if you found 20 grand coming down
the street, what you're supposed to do,
you're supposed to report it, bring
it down to the police station. Okay.
And hope that those fucking
guys don't dip into it.
And I guess after a certain amount of
days, uh, it legally becomes yours,
but then you have to pay taxes on
it and all that bit, all that shit.
And all after the fees you probably left
with anywhere from eight to 10 grand.
That's how your legally supposed to do it.
And what's annoying to me
is that you and I are up.
We're, we're held to those legal
fucking standards, but banks are not.
Banks are supposed to be watching
our money, keeping it safe. And they,
for basically,
I don't know how many goddamn years
we're loaning it out to fucking homeless
people given six figure loans to them.
And Lo and behold,
when these fucking people defaulted on
their God damn loans and the whole thing
went into the shitter, the government
fucking bails them out. They're like,
we're too big to fail.
They fucking bail him out.
They keep the bail out money and now
they added all these countries surcharges
to your,
your account in my account.
So yeah, that's, I dunno, this is what
you, this is what you do with your case.
If you have cash on the side,
uh,
use it for shit that you can
actually pay for in cash,
I guess army or save it in
case your bank ever goes, uh,
goes belly up and there's
a run on your bank.
You won't be sitting there with your
pockets turned inside out going,
can I at least have some yogurt?
But yeah, it is practically,
um, the more you read
about banking, you'll,
you'll start to understand
why corporations and and in,
in or super rich, like you
know, the entrepreneurs,
why these guys have offshore
accounts and all that type of shit.
Because these guys basically, I think
read up on banking, which you would have,
do you read up on the tax laws and
you see how the whole game is played.
You see who gets pink penalized and who
doesn't and you start thinking Jesus is
fucking ridiculous.
So let me get this straight.
When I get to this level of
wealth, all of a sudden, um,
rules don't apply to me.
Okay,
well let me work my ass off
to get to that level. Oh wait,
I can't cause they keep taxing the shit
out of me. Oh, I get it. I got to do some,
there will be bloodshed.
I mean,
I'm really overly simple
simplifying the whole fucking thing,
but that's basically how it goes down.
I mean,
that bank is not going to take
that risk on you. You know,
I got some cash on the side
that's actually good banking.
You can't have somebody just come
in and be like a, hey listen,
I got to be really stereotypical.
Now I'm going to be Italian.
I already shit on fucking southerners.
Why not do a, an Italian stereotype? A,
I got, I got, I got good credit and I got,
did I get this 50 grand in this side?
Where did I get it?
A why don't you let me worry about
that. All right. You know, I,
I, you know, somebody else
actually sent me something,
uh, about banks here. Hang on one second.
Let me read this and annoying more
people actually majored in economics or
economics. However the fuck
you say it. Uh, here we go.
Here we go.
Let me read up on this shit here.
You guys getting bored with this shit?
Well, I don't give a fuck. All right.
I do give a fuck, but I didn't
care. I wouldn't be asking,
but I'm going to continue. Hey, bill,
I've been thinking some about something
you said about taxes on your podcast.
It was about you trying to build,
build up a pile of cash and how the
government governments hitting you up for
tax money at every opportunity.
Yeah, that's my thing.
I'm trying not to put
money in the stock market.
I'm just trying to stick
it in the bank or whatever,
and they just tax the living shit out of
me. But if I stick it on the crap table,
right, which the fucking stock
market is, if I throw it in there,
then they have no problem with it, then
all of a sudden they give me a tax break.
Hey, get over here and
play the fucking game. Oh.
Um, so anyways, uh, that's
anyway, let me get back to this.
Uh, they hit you up for tax
money for every opportunity,
but that there are rich fucks out
there who've already got there.
So they don't want to get, they don't
want anyone to get rich after them.
There really is something to that.
Yeah, they got it. They got it.
They have to keep you did,
they can't have people making fucking
money and actually being able to keep it
because if, if they do,
then nobody would work.
We would just fucking kick back and relax
and maybe you have a chance to enjoy
ourselves.
Maybe sit by his stream in the Lotus
position or whatever the fuck it is you
want to do. They want you to run on the
wheel until you're fucking drooling.
And then they want whoever you created
to then take care of you in a nursing
home. And then if you can't,
they just want you to die. Um, I,
uh, somebody, okay, I tweet, I
twigged I didn't know what that means.
I twigged onto this about a year ago
when I was having a discussion with a
friend about progressive income tax,
he seemed to think that it takes
from the rich to give to the poor.
And the progressive income tax is
anticapitalists. It's not though,
because I don't know what the
fuck any of this means here.
Because earned income tax are always
higher than rates on dividends and capital
gains income. Let me, I get there,
I can read that much slower because
earned income tax rates are higher than
rates on dividends and
capital gains income. Okay?
So basically money that you
already have that's being invested,
the tax rate is lower than someone who
is out there earning the nonworking heir
or heiress who survives on dividends
and capital gains from a family fortune
like a Paris Hilton.
Uh,
their income tax is on a much lower
percentage than a working person with an
equivalent income. So basically if
you're sitting around in your ass,
you're some fucking luck. Lucky
rich kid. The money that you're,
that you basically inherited,
that you are earning off of the sh the,
there will be blood great
grandfather that you had.
The tax rate will be lesser for the Paris
Hilton Kid than someone like me if I
could earn, if I was earning that same
amount of money. Does that make sense?
Make sense to me? Um, I hope I explained
that in a way you understand it.
All right. The system punishes,
uh, work and reward rewards,
ownership with tax rates that provide
incentives for one kind of economic
activity over another.
I base this on my
experience with my Canadian.
This guy broke up with my book,
Canadian system and before I emailed you,
I had to use Wikipedia,
confirm to confirm that the u s
system works pretty much the same way.
And right there this entire email gets
thrown out the window. Wikipedia, sir,
what are you fucking me?
Maybe it does make sense on the podcast.
Let's go with this Wikipedia information.
The worst part of it is
that by implication work is
less valuable than capital.
The woman making $8 an hour at Walmart
is paying the same percentage of income
tax as the Walmart airs pay
on their divid dividends.
A medical doctor however,
pays more than twice as much
and the doctor is patching
up the sick and wounded.
The incentives in the
systems are all wrong.
So you're basically saying the borderline,
uh,
poverty person and the rich people are
paying the same amount of taxes in the
guys in the middle may or getting
the shit tax out of them. Yes,
exactly.
Exactly.
That is my fucking life. God Damn. And
I have to hit pause here, people. I,
I gotta I gotta blow my nose.
Hang on a second.
All right, I'm back. Sorry about
that. You don't what happened to me?
I was eating a bowl of wheat
checks too fast and uh,
I didn't chew up the wheat checks enough,
so they went down,
it was like swallowing,
chewing tobacco and it got soda.
Like there was just like a bunch of like,
you know,
it was in the back of my throat. So
I was like, I did that. And it's,
some of it went up into my nose,
so it was actually rechecks
one, I'm having a rough Monday.
Univer starting your weed off.
You weed out your week off with
some week checks in your nose.
We checks a healthy part of the
checks family. I would tell you guys,
I'm a big fan of the uh, check cereals.
I like, we checks, I like corn checks.
I don't like rice checks.
You know what I mean?
It's like a fucking bad movie.
It's just weak. They're just,
it's just a week cereal, you know? I
don't like those cereals that are like,
oh my God, milk. That's what, that's what
rice checks does. It just fucking shit.
It's a quitting cereal.
You know,
corn checks has some fight in them.
Quick checks. I like the jets.
We checks. I like the Patriots. We
checks our course the strongest.
Eh, you green motherfuckers,
you lost this week.
How do you like dead nine to nothing.
I love the overpaid for your fucking
tickets and you're brand new.
Fucking sublet an apartment
with the that the giants own.
You know what?
They roll out a little bit of jet signage.
Do you really think that
you won't 50% of that?
you sons of bitches,
what was it like to go to that boring
ass fucking game kick three nothing.
J e t s what the fuck?
Now the couple of fucking hours of
boring football kick six nothing.
J e t is what the fuck?
I might kick nine nothing.
Go home.
Did the fireman cry this
week? Oh, I love it.
Overrated talking shit before the season
even starts like you just won three
super bowls in a row.
Underrated having your stomach stapled.
Rex Ryan is getting better
looking every fucking week.
Son of a bitch kind of has a
jaw line now, doesn't he? Um,
all right. Just to be fair, um, I've
got to make fun of Celtics fans. Uh,
overrated.
Channing overrated.
When you're up by 11 with eight
minutes left against the Miami Heat.
Did you guys watch that game?
Then all of a sudden they all stay started
roaring back and all the felt Celtics
fans just shut the fuck up.
And then once the game was,
was decided with 12 seconds left,
they started chanting overrated again.
That was a real fucking bitchy mood.
That was real bitchy. I didn't,
I did. I was embarrassed to be associated
with that franchise. All right,
who's the moron? Who's two?
Started that chant. Um,
all right. That was, if that was, it was
just a quick little riff of underrated,
overrated,
underrated.
Having your own fucking jet
airplane with a big bed in the back,
in a giant seatbelt.
You know,
beautiful woman to sit on your Dick
in a fucking ivy to put you to sleep.
You just wake up in New York. That's
all I want. That's all I want. You know,
that's all I want out of this business.
I don't need, I don't need much.
I got to fly to New York people.
I'm going to New York on a Tuesday night,
take the red eye back to that motherfucker
and I'm doing a benefit for the
troops playing the beacon theater with a,
believe it or not,
this is,
this is the lineup on this show and
it's going to be been to three different
bases in Iraq in three
different bases in Afghanistan.
Jon Stewart is hosting.
Tony Bennett is a,
I'm assuming he's singing.
I don't think he's doing
stand up. Uh, Jerry Seinfeld,
Bruce Springsteen, Joe, Mikael,
myself,
and I think a couple of other people.
All I'm doing is eight minutes,
but uh,
I can't wait man. It's going
to be a, well, I don't want,
I don't want to do the flight,
but it's going to be fucking awesome.
That's Wednesday.
I'm flying out.
That's why I'm telling you I got all this
shit to do today because I got to, uh,
you know, I just landed here last
night. I got to do the fucking podcast.
I have an audition today.
I'm pitching a fucking show today.
I got to pay my fucking bills.
It's the first of the month I got to do
all that fucking horse shit and then I
got to jump right back on
a plane tomorrow. You know,
it's one of those fucking
weeks speaking to that dude,
I flew out to Saint Louis last week and
there was some woman who was clearing
her throat
like twice a minute from like I would
guess about Utah to Jess into Kansas.
Eh?
Hmm. Hmm. Okay.
She had this exact same way of doing it.
I swear to God.
I have never prayed for my
own plane to crash before,
but that was one of those moments I
didn't want it to crash. You know what?
I was just fantasizing that like
there was a crack in the fuselage
[inaudible] that woman
just got sucked out.
So as I was fantasizing about,
this is how fucking crazy I took it.
I actually reached down and I tightened
my seat belt and I mentally went over
how to put that fucking mask on my face
before I help the infant or child next
to me. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Okay. I saw it, you know,
it was really disgusting. No
Way. She was clearing his throat.
She was talking really
loud on her cell phone.
Just everything about her was annoying.
And whenever I see a person like that,
the first thing I do is I look
for a wedding ring, you know?
And when I don't see one, I th I
think, thank God when I do see,
see when I actually feel bad for the
man or woman that is married to that,
you know? Yeah. How could it just like,
and actually I came up with
like a philosophical question.
You know that those
dolts Sechi commercials,
the most interesting man in the world.
What do you think would happen? His,
he has his one for the, uh, the
pot smokers out there. All right.
What do you think would happen if the
most interesting man in the world met the
most annoying woman on the planet?
Yeah. All right. I want you to know,
I want you to tell me what you think
would happen because I couldn't come up
with an answer to that question.
You know,
he is the most interesting
man in the world. Well,
I would like you to meet this cunt. Who
was sitting diagonally fucking behind me.
Oh,
speaking of that underrated fucking
movie macgruber Jenny Buddy rented that.
I don't know if you'd be happy if
you paid to go see it at a theater,
but fucking, you know, unless you
have a silly sense of humor like me,
cause I would enjoy that
if I saw it in the theater.
Look at me even when I try to compliment
something I say in a dick way.
I think this is a funny fucking movie,
uh,
with a couple of really
insane monologues in it.
And uh, not to ruin anything.
Spoiler alert, spoiler alert.
I had to bring this up.
The last name of the bad
guy in the movie is cunt.
Okay. Okay. Okay.
And I'm assuming it's spelt with a K K u
n t, Z or something. But it's, you know,
we got them, we have to get cunt. I Dunno,
it's sophomore. It's fucking hilarious.
It's one of those movies you want to
watch with the female in the room cause
she's just be killing. This is stupid.
You know, you think this is funny.
Oh right God, that's grouse. Which
will just make it so much more funnier.
Macgruber two thumbs up from me baby.
All right.
This podcast is all over the place.
Let's move on to the next one. Uh,
the advice section. Why you would ask
me for advice. I don't know. Okay,
here we go.
I started listening to your podcasts about
three months ago and I really like it.
Thank you. I was inspired by a couple
of your albums on iTunes. Thank you.
Now if you ever hear me bitching
about people fucking download shit,
I'm not talking about you or
being cheap cuts. It's not you.
A bump up the bulb.
I love your comedy my whole life.
And recently I sacked up and one on
stage for a five minute spot for an open
night open mic night at a local comedy
club here in Portland, Portland.
I was really impressed by
the people that showed up.
Many of them were talentless Dick Holes,
but at least they have the guts to get
on stage and for that they deserve some
credit.
Well thank you sir.
Thank you for fucking extending
that olive branch to them.
Um, so I got up there in front
of a whopping 15 people, uh,
one of which who was my girlfriend
and talk some shit. It was,
I was pretty nervous, but my voice
was steady and I was energetic,
but most importantly I got
people laughing. There you go.
It's all you've got to do. It
might not seem like much, but I,
I had a high like no other.
I might stick with it.
Basically I write down a few prompts.
Now this isn't me people.
I swear to God,
I know I suck at reading,
but just the way that some of this shit
is written, I'm going to read this.
Basically the way this guy wrote it are
actually exactly the way he wrote it.
I might stick with it.
Basically I write down a few prompts out
for stories and quips and go to town.
I feel like open mic nights might
be the only way to get some chops.
Doing my bits for friends or two into a
mirror doesn't have the same effect as a
bunch of strangers. I'm gearing up
to put some hard work into my act.
I would like any tips on how you get
you got your chops and how you practice
your racked. All right.
Couple things. Yeah. Yeah.
You can't run it by your friends
and do it in the mirror. Um,
he could maybe say it
a few times in a way,
the club just so you can kind of
get the flow of it. Uh, but yeah,
the only way to do it is to do
open mikes. So, uh, you know,
I would do that,
just do that.
And I would also drop the attitude
that people who are starting out are
talentless Dickholtz than not.
They're fucking, you know,
if you saw me when I started out,
you would have thought that this guy
sucks because I did suck because I was
brand new at it. So you don't want to
do that. And for all, you know, the,
those air quote talentless Dick Holes
will someday be in a position in this
fucking business where they could
actually hook you up with something.
So I can not stress how important it is
to have good relationships with fellow
comedians and everybody in this
fucking business that you can.
I'm not saying that you take
it to the point that you will.
Acts actually allows somebody to walk
all over you and treat you like shit.
I'm not saying that, but don't
walk around judging people bad.
A fucking thing cut out on me again.
God Damn it. I'm sorry. I've been,
I'm putting together a new hour of comedy
and I have a bunch of standup sets on
my fucking recorder that I
never ended up listening to.
Something else,
sir,
that you might want to do if you're
doing standup is to record yourself and
listen to yourself so you can
become better as a community.
But the key is you got to listen to them.
Anybody can record them and then just
leave them on their fucking tape player or
they're fucking digital recorder, whatever
the hell you call this God damn thing.
Um, yeah, that's what I would
tell you that man, seriously,
like you will be absolutely
fucking amazed with,
with the people that you think are
going to do something and don't,
and the people who you like
and that person that and I
don't think they're going
to do shit and all of a sudden
they're directing a movie.
They're the head writer on
something. They create a show, uh,
who knows what, you don't know
what anybody's going to do. So,
uh, yeah. You know, so I
wouldn't walk around. I mean,
I'm sure you're just writing that
maybe to make me laugh or something,
but I'm just putting that out there.
All right.
Because I've seen people act like con
and then get treated accordingly by these
people that they thought were a
beneath them or whatever. It's,
it's just the worst fucking
thing that you can do in any,
any in life in general. Treating someone
else like a like shit or whatever.
I don't know.
I don't understand why people,
it really makes your life a
lot more difficult. And, uh,
some day when you die,
you know,
like there's going to be the only people,
only people at your funeral is
going to be a, you know, the,
the fucking to the guy who drives the
truck and the guy who digs the hole
or the hearse I should say.
Um, yeah. So that's, that's
the advice I would give you.
Keep doing the open mikes.
Um, it keep writing stuff,
tape record yourself and
uh, you know, and then,
and then be a good guy, be a
good guy, but then, you know,
be a good guy within reason. I
mean, like I said, don't, don't hit,
don't take shit from people.
And then also try to try to be hanging
with the people who seem the most
motivated,
most positive,
that type of shit because you'll get
caught up in it and a Yada, Yada,
fucking Yada.
That's basically it.
So we're coming to the close here or
the podcast and other kind of short one
this week just because, uh, I do
have so much shit to do here. Um,
congratulations to the rangers in the
giants for your first world series.
A giants are up three games to one.
And I was getting nervous for
giant fans. I actually, uh,
I don't mind ranger or the giants.
I have no problem with either one of them,
but I was getting nervous for the giant
fans when they were up two games to none.
And then the rangers came back and won
one game and I was like, yeah, God.
And a lot of ways the giants are
kind of like how the red sox were,
except they're in the national league.
You know how the Red Sox were
back in the day where it was,
not only do they not win, they have
to rip your fucking hard out too.
And uh,
I don't know at the risk
of pissing off ranger fans,
I think the giant fans there,
I think they've had,
I think they've had about enough,
I think it's time for the sports
gods to let 'em up off the mat,
give him a God damn world series
and range of fans. Who you kidding?
Who are you honestly fucking kitten.
You know, you're all cowboy fans.
You know,
if the cowboys record was flipped right
now and Tony Romo was living up to the
potential, you know, you know,
you wouldn't be selling out those world
series games. Okay. Now I'm a fuck.
You know, I like to range your
sense fucking uh, who was that?
Who was that fucking okay.
Who is that guy buddy something
or buddy bell that come here?
Jackass who played third
base. Um, he's not a jackass.
It just sounds funny.
I'm trying to think of guys who played
for the Rangers when I was growing up.
The fuck was it?
Somebody wrote something funny on the
Internet about how 10 years ago when the
Rangers signed a rod do
a $200 million contract,
he vowed to one day lead them to the world
series and when he struck out looking
on the New York Yankees, he finally
delivered on that promise. Oh,
Bill, he is such a cunt. I
know. I am. Yeah, I am a client.
Um, I actually watched the Patriots
game and this, uh, this sports bar
in Saint Louis and there was his fucking
old guy in there who was basically,
he had like,
like nine sports buttons on his shirt.
He had this little glow stick with
them and he's one of those guys when he
yelled,
but it still wasn't loud.
It just kept going. Whoa. The
Patriot. So when the Cheetahs,
but we always went whoa.
And everybody was ignoring them.
Anything the Patriots did was awesome.
Like this guy's fucking
shanks, this punt, right,
right off the side of his
foot for the patriot. The,
as the ball is dropping to his foot,
the guys go on.
Oh,
what a kick.
Well, he's, he's pissing off
everybody in the sports bar,
but he's too fucking old
to punch in the face.
But this is what killed me about
this guy was the people around me go,
he fucking comes here every week.
He's unbelievably annoying.
And the worst thing is, is he has, he's
fans of like six different football teams.
Like, he's a fan of the Patriots,
the bills and the dolphins.
They're all in the same fucking division.
And he's a fan of the Kansas City, uh,
chiefs. So the bills played
the chiefs, so no matter what,
he cannot lose any. Just sits
there the whole game. Whoa.
What a throw. Oh, what an interception.
Like he just wants to win the entire
fucking time. Long story short,
I had to take a picture with the
guy because he started off cute.
You know what a cute old man. And
then at one point, um, if I was,
if I was drinking,
I would have engaged with this dude it
during the second quarter and been like,
hey, how the fuck can you be fans
of every fucking team? You old cunt.
I would've done that.
But fortunately I'm not drinking.
So it took me until the fourth quarter
where I started to give him shit.
But then in the back of my
head I was like, really, Bill,
are you really going to get
into it with this old guy? Um,
but by the end of it,
he was just kind of hilarious.
So I actually took a picture with the
guy and I'm going to have that uploaded
onto the podcast.com. And,
uh, what else do I got?
I got a hyper few gigs here before I,
before I sign off on this part of this
podcast was an absolute clusterfuck.
I apologize. I had high hopes
for it, but uh, you know,
like a lot of things in life,
it just doesn't work out. Um,
all right, what do we got here? All right.
I'm going to be at the
funny bone in Columbus.
This is really one of these podcasts
that I would've stopped and restarted 10
minutes into it, but I just don't
have the fucking time are right, Bill.
We've heard your excuses. You have to mop
your kitchen floor. Nobody gives a fuck.
All right. I want to be at the, uh, the
funny bone in Columbus, Ohio. Friday,
Saturday, Sunday, November
12th, 13th and 14th.
And I'm going to try to go to that Ohio
state, Penn state game. That's my big, uh,
I don't want to be bored shitless
at the mall in Columbus move.
Then I'm going to be making,
uh,
the following week I will be in Washington
DC at the listener auditorium and
that's on a Friday, November
19th. On November 20th,
I'll be at comics at
Foxwoods in Connecticut.
I get a lot of emails from people
from Connecticut being like, Dude,
when he come to fucking Connecticut,
I'm going to be there.
It's a beautiful new room. Uh,
everybody's been raving about it.
All the comedians who have
performed there. So come on down,
check out my new hour.
And then finally,
this is the one I need your help on.
Look into your hearts.
I am playing the Moore Theater in Seattle,
Washington.
All right, for those of you
unfamiliar with the Moore Theater,
it is a legendary theater
in, uh, Seattle, Washington.
Um, I guess what a rock fans, grunge fans.
Remember that Pearl Jam Video?
I think it was even flow.
We've earned PLO when a Eddie vetter is,
is climbing out into the crowd and fucking
jumping off the balcony and stepping
on people's heads and shit at,
that's where they filmed that.
And I have to sell a lot of fucking
tickets. I'm a third of the way there.
So if you,
and some of you are drunk buddies
want to come down for the love of God,
please come down to the show because a,
I've got a ton of tickets
to sell and clear channel.
I don't know what they've done to radio
but they've, they've taken off, you know,
my guy up there was Marty Riemer,
which I heard he has a podcast
now if you live in Seattle,
fuck those radio stations
that took them off.
Listen to his podcast because hopefully
I'm going to be doing that to hype my
show.
Uh,
I'm kind of running out of ways to hype
shows now with what they're doing to
radio.
For those of you out of the loop,
I think clear channel basically wants to
have for Djs for the entire country and
uh, you walk into these radio stations
now, they don't even have a receptionist.
They have an automated system
for you to figure out how to uh,
get to where you're going out on.
It's yet another thing,
and I'm sure you people who are all for
these kinds of technologies like I love
when people like try to support
those automated checkout lines.
Like they always say the same thing,
you know,
and you're standing there looking at this
poor bastard behind the fucking Reggie.
You mean that person with the fucking job?
You really want to see him be a poor
bastard. What would you rather be?
A poor bastard behind a fucking a cash
register or a poor bastard you fucking
homeless and don't have a God damn job.
I hate when people do like dumb shit
like that just to try to enhance their
fucking point.
If you fucking believe in that technology,
support the technology,
don't start,
start saying what the person behind
the fucking registers thinking.
Even though I'm doing
the same goddamn thing.
But I think I can go out on a limb and
say that most people would rather have a
fucking job than be homeless.
All right?
Lots of yelling this week, Bill, as
opposed to what? Every other quiet week.
Um,
and then the final two gigs of this year
before I take my month off and I begin
my martial arts classes, joking. Um,
I'm going to be at COBB's comedy club in
San Francisco. Uh, December 2nd, third,
fourth,
and fifth,
and I'm going to be at the Improv
in Bray, California, the 16th,
17th, 18th, and 19th of
December. Uh, come on down.
This new hour is starting to take shape.
Actually had some guy come up to me, uh,
this weekend in St Louis and was like,
that was absolutely hilarious.
I didn't think it was as funny
as let it go, but I liked it.
It's like, thank you sir. Well,
it's not done yet, you know.
Thank you for starting to compliment
me and then giving me a little dig.
Hey, you look great. You're not
as fat as you used to be. Um,
all right. And this guy, hey, he
really had a pudgy face. He really did.
He had one of those. He was a
white dude, but he was like so fat.
He was starting to look Asian. You
know what I mean? When he gets so fat,
your ice like that, uh, that
precious girl, you know,
you know when the fat just starts building
up on your cheeks, all of a sudden,
you know,
that's how you start to look,
whether that be in an incredible way
to sell some fat burning products.
Are you so fat that you're starting
to look Asian in your eyes,
even though you're not? Well, listen,
that is offensive. Well, line up
behind the Italians in the southern us,
that's what this podcast was this week.
I'm trying to get fired from
my own podcast. I'm trying to,
I want a lot of complaints and have
people say that I need to apologize, um,
to different groups of people so that I
could be fired from my podcast because I
think I need a fucking vacation
from the shit. I really do. No,
I don't actually love doing this shit.
I just got too much shit to do this week.
So that's it. That's the end of this
fucking podcast. I'm uploading it.
I apologize for my singing.
I apologize for the scatter brained,
uh, podcast that this
was, but I think, I think,
I like to think that there was
some moments. It was a good rental.
Anyways, that's it. Uh, and
thanks to everybody who's
been a buying the, uh, the,
Oh gee,
his ringtone on the [inaudible] podcast.
If you want to donate to the podcast
99 cents, look into your heart,
go to the [inaudible] podcast
dot [inaudible] dot com
and download the ogs has
ringtone. I'm actually getting
a new cell phone this week.
I was going to try to hold out
for the new iPhone when it's, uh,
not the new iPhone, the iPhone
when it switches over to Verizon.
But my blackberry is shitting the bed.
I can't get emails on it and uh,
the letter and doesn't work anymore
unless I fucking sprained my thumb pushing
it down. And, uh,
I think I'm going to get that droid phone.
What do you guys think about that one?
Is that a good one? I want
Verizon. I want to stay with,
with Verizon because as far as where
I travel, I'm going to get the droid.
I should've just gone out and gotten
the fucking thing right and just had you
guys shit all over me that it's a bad
goddamn phone as opposed to now where I'm
going to get like 50 different opinions.
Like, dude, do not get the droid.
It fucking sucks. Get this phone.
Okay. Uh, yeah. I have Verizon.
Keep that in mind. Suggest
a smartphone for me. Okay.
That is it. Thank you. One and all. I
hope you guys have a great God damn week.
And, uh, and that is it. That
is it. That is a park. Oh,
Jesus Christ. What a
horrible Eddie Ed. That is
really bill. Really? That's all I got.
Oh.
[inaudible]
oh.